oh yeah oh yeah amnesia the Dark Descent
we're back baby canteen how long has it
been
I got exciting news you probably read in
the title maybe you don't know what it
means but I'm Nisha I don't know how
many years has it been since it came out
oh my god five years it must have been
five years six years
damn this is the game that changed my
life I will forever be grateful for this
game they up there today sorry I keep
getting sidetracked hard mode they have
hard mode now okay so this means
autosave it is disabled so only manual
saving which cost for tinderboxes what
okay this is terrible sanity dropping to
zero resulting death that doesn't happen
that often but I think your sanity drops
quicker now less oil and Turner boxes
throughout the levels monsters are
faster spot the player more easily deal
more damage to stay around for longer
and there's no danger music with a while
yeah oh my god and if you die if you die
you have to start over I think no you
can still save okay
damn oh I'm a damn they should be ultra
hard mode where like if you die you have
to start over because I remember the
reason why I got so freaked out in the
first game was cuz I did such a good job
like I didn't want to interact with the
monster whatsoever I'm like I don't know
what's gonna happen when he gets me but
I'm not gonna find out
so that tension of not knowing what
would happen was so powerful I think I
think I don't know man I don't want to
talk too much let's just you know what I
will talk too much I wanted just for the
sake of reminiscing since we're here
doing that anyway uh I wanted to check
out my first my first video yeah I liked
my old leaders back in the day what you
got a problem with that deleted video
what video
unavailable this video has been removed
for violating YouTube's Terms of say
what what what did I what did I say this
is a nice comment I didn't realize this
so it was actually kind of controversial
that's why I wanted to show part one
because in part one this was one of the
first videos I ever made and in it I
said I said specifically I don't want to
joke around while playing this like I
genuinely want to be scared so asked my
channel progressed and I played horror
game after horror game after horror game
after horror game people started getting
really mad at me for not you know taking
the game seriously or like me not
getting scared in the game which is just
it would have been dishonest for me to
pretend that I was being scared just to
please what people wanted after you play
in a certain amount of horror games you
don't get scared the same way because
you understand how the mechanics work
and the more you understand something
the less scared you get this is how it
is because that new the more comfortable
you are with it and what's the the fear
of the unknown is them it's the scariest
thing because that's our imagination and
well I forgot the expression but you
understand what I'm saying hopefully a
lot of people have me accountable for
what I said in part 1 but I can honestly
tell you the reason why I said that was
yes because I wanted to be scared but
number two I was very shy and very timid
and I didn't feel comfortable being open
on camera I just it was so weird you
have to understand that this is in 2010
the gaming channels wasn't big back then
at least in the same sense it was weird
to do this it was weird to record
yourself playing a video game and I just
didn't feel comfortable at all so you
have this comment of me saying that's
not even funny
I don't know why I did that and this
guy's like saying everyone says he
changed he didn't change he just became
confident and I agree
I'd really if there's one trait that
I've gained from doing YouTube is just
becoming more comfort comfortable with
myself and I'm really happy with that I
used to be so insecure about everything
here's another one saying it too that's
so nice to read actually this is making
me emotional me it's not like he's
really changed so much he he says
confident everyone seems to complain one
then another yeah it's funny
I would also get applauded by a lot of
people for not cutting my videos that's
cuz I didn't know how to edit just like
I was so terrible at it so when I
started adding my videos to make them
more entertaining people like what the
hell man you used to do uncut but then
again I would add if you watch this
playthrough I understand that the pros
and the cons but you see here puzzles is
me getting stuck on the same puzzle this
entire episode which I guess has a charm
to it but I mean I could have just cut
it down I've never faced pumped so much
in my life look at this comment love
hurts but he's really been stupid here
like no one likes to watch someone being
stuck at a game that's just frustrating
it's not entertaining for every any one
people just get pissed off I think since
this is a hard mode I do want to keep
this uncut I do want to keep this
somewhat reminiscent of the over the
pass
hopefully people won't hold me to
accountable for the changes oh it said
here I didn't even need to go out okay
let's begin guys I've been looking for a
reason to replay this game for so long
I've been wanting to do it but I would
like I don't really know so when they
announced it forgotten
shadow haunting me I must hurry my name
is Daniel I live in London Mayfair what
have I done this is crazy
don't focus
genius such a brief start simple
beginning
no long cutscene just just that and then
you're off I love it
the audio as well it's just genius you
forget how you're playing so many bad
horror games you forget how good this is
a memento has been added follow the
liquid trail and find it stores
I also remember this game it didn't
treat you like you were an idiot as well
you actually have to figure out stuff by
yourself chair hello
this made all my fans cry mr. chair how
could you
I'm so sorry I will never interact with
you again however this is all about the
plan it's already my sanity's love
forgot how you check it there you go
yeah no crystal clear why am I so slow
this is supposed to be ours liquid oh oh
I don't trust you
see just that scared me so much if you
don't know what's waiting algorithm for
the fluence mr. chair chair mode
activate all right oh yeah you can pull
up some paintings I remember I guess we
really need to look inside a lot of the
game just had such a simple mechanic the
fact that you can interact with objects
and that just made it so fun I think
that I watch some interviews with oh my
god
interviews with the developers and they
were they were saying just that like
it's basically a walking simulator it's
a really boring game but the fact that
you can
we really feel the insanity of the
character this all of this scare that oh
my god it's still so creepy I love it
you guys remember this story I don't
remember it that well I'm actually
really intriguing just to see what the
story actually is I don't think I'm even
trying to understand it okay clearly we
can't trust this plain spooky too spooky
you know what let's have some balls
let's see oh yeah our sanity I forgot
this is actually bad for us you're in
the dark too long and you drop your
sanity and you have to oh my god I'm an
idiot all right we're clear okay
it would be pretty embarrassing to die
this old are we dead it boys okay this
is so fun yeah
hello I'm low framerate oh oh god it's
I'm low insanity I need to find like
anything shower using the mechanics
cheese that I just wasted
oh yeah that's my insanity
and it's not real Felix damn this is
actually harder to play I am keep
forgetting what I'm gonna say what's
going on I actually think this is where
I am that episode one
okay maybe I should keep the episodes a
lot shorter
well more modest she says
oh yeah we get our Lantern a good old
pal yep
and I think there's some oil in here no
we still have no oil well we have oil
okay we actually have to be conservative
now it's like the expression are we
going here
you never knew what you were gonna see
me they really knew how to build up
suspense man
they got a do they got to make another
one they gotta make a Nisha - I need it
I need it
all right let's cry
I think we found something I don't think
I was the scare hello
Thank You the boldest 1839
I wish I could ask how much you remember
I don't know if there will be anything
left after I consumed this drink oh yeah
this our older though be afraid Daniel I
can't tell you why but know this I
choose to forget try to find comfort and
strength in that fact there is a purpose
you are my final effort to put things
right God willing the name Alexander of
Brandenburg still invoked bitter anger
in you if not this will sound horrible
go to the inner sanctum find Alexander
and kill him
his body is old and weak we know that it
was young and strong way to prop
yourself I'll match for you one last
thing a shadow is following you great a
living nightmare
breaking down reality I have tried
everything and there is no way to fight
back you need to escape it as long as
you can redeem us both Daniel descend
into the darkness where Alexander waits
and murder him your former self Daniel
young nice to compliment yourself I like
my old self he must such a clever way to
start a horror game because not only do
you have an interesting spot but you
also have the fear of the unknown a
shadow following me what do you mean
what does that mean I have no idea but
I'm already like
don't waste the lightning Felix they're
gonna yell at you like they always do
cuz I'm an idiot I need to also see
there must be no reason for this room
right could I be wrong trail I'm
actually getting scared this is awesome
where am I going there it doesn't really
make sense cuz we didn't get anything
from here we just got the wait what is
it Matt internal so nothing there must
be something here oh the lever yes I
remember there we go
okay there we go
and France all whoo
I'm smiling the whole way through this
has to be a horror game
Alexander is it inside the castle in a
manner of speaking
dump bring the lamp you'll bring the
door finally have you not I don't
believe I have is it connected to the
what did you call it the inner sanctum
all right my most precious chamber
Daniel and it lies well beyond the
refinery in fact it lies beneath the
very stone of brennenburg Brandenburg
Yoho okay I'm gonna go visit da fabrica
and like what Toria owl yeah that is not
where I want to go hey I got an idea I
bet no one tried this one it's tough and
plain it can't be torn up by hand or
tools fine
I'll be back mr. gu
that was not very tasty
uh-huh
all right I think I need my penis to do
that but I don't want to use straight
now that's Ryan
everything has a gender somewhere just
got triggered
okay that's all right I think I know no
go away go away
shoosh shoosh I think ah look at that
you got to always look yeah yeah I don't
think this is it
whoa hey Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
shoosh sheesh all right bringing you
with me just for shielding Oh God
apparently you're not supposed to click
on big doors why don't you talk to no
okay I think this is it I think I
remember oh god damn this is confusing
back in the day laboratory sorry where
are we going refinery can it be solved
yeah from the laboratory we get the acid
or whatever okay all right Alexa
oh my god
oh how is this game still to this day
hey how you doing buddy how is this game
still to this day outclassing almost any
horror game I played in so long sorry
because you know so many games
developers were inspired by emotion the
lack of Chimney to property event to
properly event the fumes from my most
recent experiment has taken its toll on
the soul on many of my less stable
ingredients in storage some seem
unaffected but many are stained by the
fumes and will be difficult to cyllage I
shall do what I can and move them to the
wine cellar so means we need to go to
the wine so chemically angry happy mood
from the laboratory to the wine cellar
okay so we need to wise things shaking
we need to get what we need and we need
alright relax
I should be more cooperate so my third
attempt to produce the artificial bit
tire by day the former compounds like
the potency I need but I since I'm
closed calamine and orbit-man
are given and the cute cry it binds them
well but this time I will attempt aqua
regia instead of aqua Fortis and hope it
will produce a more even solution what
in the world
the experiment was unsuccessful the
solution is highly acid okay so we need
to make the answer let's make some acid
brauch
come on perhaps one day I will return
one day I will return if it wasn't for
that thought of you my love I wouldn't
be able to go on when I find myself
doing terrible things I take comforting
as long as I'm able to think of you and
longed for a life together I know I'm
better than the others I weep for them
they lust for power without restraint
where I only crave for fair crave fair
judgment is they in a safe return
yeah it's almost like
oh it's the water month dessert he made
it my accident didn't he Oh sharks
so you hear that someone's upstairs
walking on the wood where you came from
how freaky is right the simple things
thinking about how different the horror
game genre I came after this with all
the jump scares and the fire mags of
Finance of Freddy's
this is where the wine cellar is that
doesn't make any sense
[Music]
hello flipping textures archives it's
down here
I sported on
so this is like our hub area let's check
out our case
[Music]
ooh I remember this place okay alright
next episode we will investigate further
yes if you want another episode smash
like would very much appreciate it maybe
we can bring back the daily let's place
for the sake of this I think that could
be really fun and any support you want
to give I appreciate and if other than
I'll see you guys tomorrow
check out merch everybody link in
description bye [ __ ] teleporting
stones
let's see oil
oh I shouldn't use that